[Applause]
well that wouldn't be surprised if I
told you I'm feeling pretty good you
know the Oscars are I think they've been
going on bringing three years
I'm kind of you know joining a bigger
apparatus so gonna be you know pretty
familiar in some ways I think it'll but
I think it'll be fun I mean they're
allowing us to be relaxed or they're not
you know stretching us into some
moldable you know we don't fit so
I guess that's yeah that's no secret
yeah it is I don't have a seat I've
given my seat as the nominee to one of
my family members the whole family's
coming out so I will be backstage
hanging out with the crew that'll be a
special little shot right back here so
sorry
etc
[Music]
their difference in the acting
you know no it's a funny thing I and
some people in the chat tech might know
I just did some different arts on
General Hospital the soap opera and when
I did that before I did that I thought
well and when I gonna have to act
differently am I gonna have to act like
a soap opera what I got so far so good
and what does that even mean and then
when I got there I realized no I don't
have to act any differently that all I
thought my job is to act as
realistically in the parameters of this
world you know actors realistically in
that impossible and because the right is
different because the way they should
differ the Lighting's different the
makeup the characters you know and and
all the dynamics and all that we are
different you change but that acting
and as for is kind of the same whether
you're on the soap opera on an
independent film or on you know super
large budget phone it's just that the
world and the context around you changes
and you have to
ah you know they all each movie has our
project has its own reality and so
that'll change slightly the basically
several shorts today forth between our
experience and Iran change the way of
that yeah you know when I first started
acting I thought I didn't want to know
all right maybe I was taught or whatever
but I didn't want to know about the
technical side it was always about like
making the emotions genuine you know
really living in you know really
believing it and I still believe that
way and hopefully that that way of
working has been ingrained in me so that
performances are emotionally honest if
that's what they demand but I do see
movies
what is a for the collaborative art form
that they are now and so I know that
there are yes the actors should be
living you know realistically and acting
realistically but there's cameras and
you know there's lighting and there's
blocking and there's all these other
things considerations and so instead of
trying to ignore all that I try to work
right here
[Music]
yeah about that documentary my mother is
a she's gonna children's book author for
decades now she has over I think 40
titles maybe maybe even more than that
and she recently has started writing and
publishing young adult fiction in her
first young adult novel is called the
Menem 1/4 metamorphosizes which is a
nice retelling of Ovid's metamorphoses
in a contemporary high school setting
which is also very strange because at
the same time I was writing a book with
teenage characters so nothing against my
mom but I didn't want to read you want
to read her book and so I haven't read
the whole thing I did there's a poetry
class in the book and they read in the
end she includes some of the characters
poetry so I read the poetry sections
before the audiobook now she has adapted
the book into a stage play is she
putting on at the top of the theater and
by some other crazy coincidence or maybe
we're just instinct different related I
have also been interested in capturing
young people in the theater and I'm
working on a project at Yale using a
live stage play but also digital
technology and cameras and projections
in different ways and actually not
experienced in it in a new way so I just
thought well my mom's you know doing it
too so why why fight it so you're making
a documentary about the process of
putting on that
[Applause]